[Music]
well it looks like the upcoming season
of bachelor in paradise was a success at
least for these two amanda stanton and
robbie hayes who film the ABC hit
earlier this summer were photographed
holding hands and smiling while
strolling through West Hollywood
California on Saturday which has us
thinking they get together on the show a
source all but confirmed as much telling
et the two have been seeing each other
since the latest season of paradise
wrapped production adding that he really
makes her smile the reality TV duo also
took in a Dodgers game over the weekend
with a few of their fellow bachelor
alums he just makes me so happy like I
love being around him earlier this month
the 27 year old mom of 2 told ET that
she was single but ultimately glad she
went back on bachelor in paradise after
her engagement to Josh Murray ended last
year I was definitely hesitant about it
but I think one of the reasons where I
wanted to go back was to kind of end it
on a different note I think I had more
fun this time with what serious didn't
rush into anything
so yeah I'm glad I went back and did it
a little bit differently
[Music]
you